in Saint Petersburg yesterday vladen
tatarsky a well-known Russian military
blogger was presented with a statue
according to Russian State media a bomb
was hidden inside
and when it exploded it killed tatarsky
injuring at least 32 others he'd been a
vocal supporter of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine see if we've been saying in this
video last year we will kill everyone we
will rob everyone we need
Russia's pointed the finger at Ukraine
for the killing but a Ukrainian official
called it Russian domestic terrorism it
follows the murder of another prominent
supporter of the invasion Darian dugin
with a Car Bomb near Moscow last year
Russia's also under pressure from the
U.S over American journalist Evan
gershkovic arrested on spying charges
last week